working on unlocking the FPS on PC
that's good yeah
it's uh I'm curious to see how it shapes
up and I hope that they continue to
support it too so supposed to have that
shark tank character in here saw YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
think I can Jason
[Music]
is it
[Applause]
so my my car the game
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello
hello hey hey Ben hi how are you doing
John Luke I'm doing great man um we are
it's it's Wednesday my dude holy crap is
it for Wednesday it's Wednesday my did
oh my gosh we made it we're out here
we're streaming normally Persia would be
streaming on Wednesday however she's has
horrible construction happening at our
house which I've been there my old place
that I recently moved out of had they
were building a whole ass apartment next
to us and they would wake up at 7:00 in
the morning on a Saturday and the sound
goes off oh just go for it
so anyway you're stuck with us today and
we're playing bleeding edge the the hot
new Ninja Theory game yeah that just
came out it's it's like it's like
overwatch but through the lens of
Anarchy Reigns yes which we both kind of
like we both have a soft spot for
Anarchy Reigns yeah but I sent you an
invite why don't you uh oh you sent me
yeah I sent you an invite except sick
I've joined I'm in alright cool cool are
you I don't see you in there first I'm
up at the top there it is just like a
sigh all right uh let's just get right
into this game Brandon calls not
remember playing in the beta mm-hmm you
know yes yeah we we checked out the beta
earlier liked it kind of curious about
how much of a audience that will find
there was no hype around the game
yesterday well no one who came out no
one's talking about it granted a lot of
things going on right now
yeah oh so I saw someone in the chat
earlier mentioned lawbreakers and I
totally would if it were still love I
like that game yeah same
just because I hope it won't because it
is a it's the first party thing from
Microsoft it's also cross so yeah like
I'm playing you're playing it on Steam
right now the Windows Xbox platform and
then you can split on Xbox no Scott
cross played between all those systems
so I'm hoping that it's it's better and
it has it finds his audience and that
they keep updating it because it seems
little bare-bones
at launch yeah I'd like maybe a few more
modes or something but it is the other
thing too is it if you don't have it
with your game pass it's 30 dollars like
it's it's a journey to our game that's
true it's also on game path so if you
have game past
you're like Isles new games out might as
well try it yeah so a good old time the
webcam alright so you you're thinking
support is who you're gonna go with oh
I'll take it out you're tanking somebody
already picked on the boy Damon so I'll
pitch jeez what the healer lady is real
fun so yeah by the way cuz we're both
playing I don't know how much look at
the chat I don't know if you have that a
little at all I do I'll try to check in
with it as much as I can there's a lot
of people talking about how much they
love a gnar he reigns rock rock Alucard
you know that's what we're here for
if there's one takeaway we can we can
all have from the stream is that Anarchy
Reigns is maybe not a good video game
but it's it's a game that I love it's a
game that I love what if we by way of
playing bleeding edge get more eyes
in Turkey rains somehow I agree also
they added music to the actual game why
this guy's just spinning around guys
doing some warm-up matches I'm feeling
pretty confident I think we're still
definitely in the phase 2 where people
are learning how to play this that man
went invisible
I'm gonna focus the healer down yeah
whoo everybody spins oh the collection
phase was happening I wasn't even paying
attention she has talked about people
not playing the objective earlier and
then I'm the one not playing the
objective oh it's classic yeah
definitely not not over watch it's got
like an overwatch kind of stylistic to
it
woo boy real dangerous situation
ah geez tries all my all my people have
died every group yo beyblade all the
time LIF this is just gonna be a stream
where we talk about a whole bunch of
just dumb stuff that we really like I
think your your mic might have done the
the flip thing oh my god I hate it
hello can hear me now hello yeah yeah
yeah okay cool let me know how that
happened this is more like plants vs.
zombies garden warfare that's also a
game I enjoy garden warfare was
basically yeah no all my canisters are
gone now try to get out of there rather
play this over overwatch way more
engaging I I like the melee focus of it
- it feels unique it's lowering again
still it sounds fine to me right now
okay
I'll mention something if I hear it
though okay it's better but it's a bit
back and forth okay I need to fit I need
to fix this
but it's driving me nuts
yeah
oh my goodness
oh you've got your Mac out shoot I shall
just want to ran back to you
I don't really do much I mean yikes
this is the first day Renan says he
doesn't know if they're gonna let me on
the podcast as we could the audio issues
I'm actually not on but I also wouldn't
let myself on if my mic was still acting
up it's a hard issue to to pinpoint
because you can't hear it you have to
depend on everyone else for it
that's like sometimes like totally fine
it's it's doing the thing now it's doing
it right now
excellent yeah exactly yeah sometimes
it'll it'll act up and other times it'll
be fine so do you have like maybe
different chord to kind of plug it in or
maybe that's it maybe the lips kind of I
don't know if it's the chord I don't
know if it's the mixer and if it's the
microphone I'll probably spend a day
later in this week figuring it out
[Music]
the healers almost dead there we go
no whoa man
Oh God
please the the bike I play as tank my
thing I'm not doing I'm not doing that
hot with her I'm gonna OH
mm-hmm yeah we saw the support should we
get to it's two supports two extra I I'm
still not sure what the meta is exactly
in this try the the NIT Hager he's
really good maybe my favorite DPS CPS if
he's any better like Damon's cool and
all cuz he's like a ninja with graffiti
but yeah
then we're getting worked we are okay
like I said this is the first one of the
day person there we go perfect okay now
we got to get to B and slam these things
in so we can get some points it's not
I'm off I'm off there we go bam bam
there we go
where are they all right and showing up
the activated the [ __ ] it's too late
though we already did it yeah now I'm
gonna die oh they're uh they're healers
being very very active uh let's see
Jordan says one damage to support in one
tank seems to be ideal the two damage
instead works too yeah I kind of like by
default just automatically assume the
the like party makeup from an MMO is
where you want to be it makes sense yeah
so let's not say where Ritchie is in the
chat and he's actually really busy
working on a working on some some game
stuff so he's not been able to be on the
chats as much right now but you will see
a bunch of his work coming through so
it's true that's true see situations
like that where it's like four people
and it's like I can't do anything like
it yeah I'm not gonna be able kill them
I try to evade but like you really can't
you just kind of die like one in a
situation like that and I that doesn't
feel great you know yeah there's you've
got a kind of death ball your way around
it seems
anyway they've got like all the Power
Cells so we need oh yeah we can cut them
off I think they're going to be there a
couple of them at B
where'd they go they might have ran off
to the other one oh no they're trying
they're trying to hand in no okay got
him stunned oh come on oh oh I almost
had him yes yes yes yes yeah yes Juna
nope and then I got to kill me
but I at least didn't get hit her killed
him
so I feel good about that so that's
that's fair
that was that was bad no first we got as
many points as we did though Yeah right
yeah okay we'll get him in the next one
yeah yeah
oh dang you got the kill assist thing I
like it that's good come home it's it's
going got a lot of stuff going on and
yeah somehow making it work my fad will
bring been mostly good except for the
microphone thing but yeah will this be
on playstation i don't know cuz it's got
its got that microsoft it's a microsoft
exclusive yeah sure so many people play
the healer with the car over I yeah I
don't I don't care for him as much when
I tried him in the beta a might because
she I think she's the melee healer and
we got that melee gravitation thing
we're like melee all the time maybe that
makes sense
anyone's linked to materials over weight
I don't know if it's overrated but it's
it's not it's not living up to what I
was looking for but it's still good I
think the more I think about it I
definitely feel like it has some some
issues that I find a little
disappointing but I still I still really
really like it a lot I think it's a
great game like I think it's somebody on
Twitter I follow kind of put it well
where they said that basically like what
it does really really great it like it
does fantastically like when you're in
the moment and you're doing the shooting
and you're doing what the game wants you
to do it's fantastic but it has enough
small little things that matray and
distract you and keep you from doing
that stuff yeah that's that's sort of
how I feel I think that's a fair
assessment
I think you're you're good to do a
healing or oh yeah I'm doing a heal well
we'll do it to heal party and see how
that goes I might switch to it tank
instead of DPS still oh yeah why don't
you do that so we'll have tank DPS 2
healers I'll play is the the motorcycle
ad since people are asking for just kind
of mix it up we Jensen spins also
they're like unlockable cosmetics I
found kind disappointing like the skins
aren't are just kind of color spots
there's nothing kind of super exciting
there I think at least not yet they
might yet
put some more stuff in I agree it feels
like a game that well I'll say
half-baked just like they need a little
bit more time maybe okay I'm gonna head
towards get you that he'll healer
there we go come here you I put the wall
up and get you some more heels let's
just get out all right
drop in
Oh No
there's platforming tube yeah they've
got like uh I like surprising amount of
platforming in it I actually don't mind
it - oh that sucked
I'm gonna try to sneak C while no one's
on it
Oh No dr. boom sauce I'm so sorry
got to DPS coming up on me okay I'm
gonna get got here yep
what company is behind this game that
would be a ninja theory who if you're
not familiar with their name they are
the guys who made DMC Devil May Cry they
made Elwood hell-blade they made
Heavenly Sword they made enslaved
Odyssey to the West they've they've done
a lot of stuff a lot of good [ __ ] too
yes so the melee combat feels it's made
by people who know what they're doing
yeah which is why the Anarchy Reigns
comparison actually kind of holds off
because it like they I always feel like
ninja theories sort of like the European
equivalent of platinum yeah I could see
it like I think there's certain
parallels to them and Anarchy Reigns is
made by platinum so I think the
comparison holds
oof I shouldn't run over here okay so
let's see they're winning so I think a
big problem right now is people don't
people do some reasons don't know to
focus healers for sure okay let's just
have to be in take that I'm into it
let's just let's just start there nope
never mind
oh we can get the one in the back that's
about to activate okay let's do that
yeah yeah and then we can swoop back
down because I don't think there's
anyone over here or is there there is
he's almost dead
how is he not yeah how is he not dying
what the heck is going on that was weird
forgot that point here Oh fine just sit
on the heels you know I gotcha I gotcha
I gotcha
hey yeah okay got one got one yes I'm
gonna keep you healed there we go
heck yeah there we go alright alright
let's get you some shots grab a then
we'll move it on be alright it's got to
be and then we'll probably meet them
coming back from see ya
right on the edge
okay okay okay cool cool guy we got some
good stuff there okay yeah we're doing a
little better let's stay on this one
here this one's gonna be the one coming
up yeah Oh No
ah daddy's going on mio - I want to play
in the o2 but I'm waiting for the PC
version to come out so she is she's a
good tank she's a good tank
I only buttercup a lot yeah I really
take that thing back
they're doing a very good job protecting
oh my gosh oh no nope everyone's dead
and I'm by myself who seems like a soul
always have a dedicated community that's
a good point to like there are gonna be
people who who play this very good I
think so again especially because of the
cross play I think like what would
normally have been like three disparate
platforms with separate communities all
play with each other so I think it'll
keep the game a little bit more alive
yeah that in the fact that it's going to
be on or that is on game pass yeah get a
healer
whoa oh no now god yes I come in Oh am I
wearing a Witcher shirt I am wearing a
Witcher shirt I'm gonna grab because
they all walked out of the room I always
forget that you can stand still and
press right trigger to parry yeah the
parry is a difficult one to kind of get
a get a handle on especially when it's
like so chaotic like that with so many
people it can be kind of tough
oh yeah cos your your instinctive
reaction is to like dodge dodge away
yeah kind of looks like Paragon Oh
remember Paragon I do I've played a lot
of that like like a beta Ford or
something I think I had a friend who was
really in a Paragon and I remember
everyone like there was a very vocal
group of people who were super bummed
when epic shut that down yeah okay let's
keep going yeah yeah yeah keep this
train rolling Oh said you left American
to a stay in the party if I leave that's
the question you're my party still okay
cool oh nice so I unlocked the mod for
her to have her mount up quicker uh
we're playing on PC with controllers I'm
playing with a controller anyway I don't
know if you're playing it actually
Cleveland it actually recommends you
play the controller when you turn the
game on it says like a rule really yeah
cause use a gamepad exactly yeah it's I
think it's definitely a it's a
third-person action game like you
probably do all right with me board
mouse but I feel like it's definitely
it's fully better off with a controller
today now I'm a Paragon I know I'm
thinking about all the different gains
that were like not bad or pretty good
but just like kind of fell off and died
Paragons won your play dirty bomb that's
another one yeah that one that one was
pretty good that one also kind of died
so how did you download the Windows
version of it so someone asking how you
download Oh windows there's an Xbox app
that is like you're basically like an
Xbox type dashboard that you can use to
like download games and stuff and I just
did it through that because I have game
passages you know logged in with my
account and that just gave it to me oh I
get to DPS this time better shred them
dead I also like this guy because when
he he idles for a bit he actually starts
playing his guitar and you can hear it
that's pretty good world reminds to
sunset overdrive does have a little
sunset overdrive vibe to it yeah I love
only some sunset overdrive overdrive
along a really good game do you think
games will get delayed more because of
what's going on uh yeah I think that's
inevitable I think right now we're
seeing a lot of games that were pretty
much just about finished and we're ready
to go out and so this you know the
current pandemic hasn't affected them
but I think you're gonna start seeing
other things get delayed as stuff
happens I wouldn't be surprised you know
they haven't confirmed it's gonna get
laid but square kind of put out a
message up front saying like hey you
know this could potentially affect Final
Fantasy and we'll let you guys know if
it does so they're not saying it's going
to but there
being upfront about the possibility
because I think even they're not really
a hundred percent sure yeah
Jonah why me being this like I really
like let's let's fight all these people
that was a a spicy call
how do I already have two points from
kills this four kills yeah I think I
think we're all separated we need to get
everyone together
oh they're delivering we need to hurry
yeah yeah
get health oh no you're all alone yeah
I'm gonna die I just like came around a
corner and saw everyone there and uh
Derek Derek is clarified for me
apparently it might only be at physical
copies of Final Fantasy that kept delay
not digital yeah that makes sense
like um yeah even like some online games
like I'm curious like destiny for
example so there bungees all pretty much
working from home and they did that like
a week before the new season came out
which at that point that season's mostly
locked in you know they can do a lot of
that kind of work from home but things
like a brand new season you know how do
you handle things like voice recording
and a lot of that stuff I don't know
yeah I'm coming to back you up thank you
let's try and get this healer boy
yeah
I'd like this stage because it's kind of
train that runs through a dad for it
again big big fan of that all that
buttercups skin look different yeah and
yet that the enemy's got mmm-hmm
that I'm just beating me up right now so
much I'm trying to Dodger that granny
goodness I'll shoot yet but we got we
got play as the the granule wonderful
she's hot man she's tough though yeah
she looks she looks like a Pixar
character straight she dies Oh Buttercup
is annoying to fight healer healer help
me please oh my god
oh my god finally took God oh Jesus
she's tough get this healer out of here
no oh it's right there it was so close I
got you I got you you should jump in
oh yeah we're like one of the other
people who've been talking about it if
you want to though only if you want
there we go got the healer which means
it's open season oh I could use some
eels myself
eels please
I healers back our healer has not been
healing me very well
is it huh down oh oh there we go I can
actually do the kill oh no I my server
connection is well I got kicked
oh no oh no well do you want to just
quit out of that match oh yeah
I'm not gonna get a penalize there
anything I'm a I don't know uh there we
go
geez that was yeah like my matches
unfair to your teammates accounts loss
and a leaver penalty no no I don't want
to do that to you well no I just want to
make sure it doesn't stop us from
matchmaking again you will backfill and
be matched with other players will take
longer but you won't owe it straight up
stops like XP gain and stuff for leaving
and also puts you at the back of the
line for matchmaking oh I wanted his
gosh like yeah I'd say you go on to your
next one and then I'll wait for you to
come out of that because this one's only
got a minute left
okay I gotta leave your uh I got I got a
boot you from my my thing that's that's
fair okay let's just keep going on my
and then yeah I'll wait up for you to
get out of the one that you've been to
all right
hope that connection issue was on the
game's end and not my end I've not had
any issues with like internet connection
is dreaming but you know who knows yeah
oh my god this is perfect I'm about to
slam dunk 20 things in here
and we might win now because of it Oh
both people on my team and their team
got hit by the trains so they just
dropped everything right on the point oh
[ __ ] so I just scooped it all up damn
wish I could be there oh man
oh this is a good question words is
asking if we believe in the Silent Hill
rumors I like to believe in them because
I want to see Silent Hill come back in
some way that's not a pachinko machine
but I'm already dealing with the fact
that that's where metal gear is gonna
live forever well so the I mean the
rumor is that light is Metal Gear 2 is
that Kojima is like doing it right like
yeah like they they've reconciled enough
that Konami is like all right fine we'll
let you have the license out sound he'll
to you which is probably like a better
proposition for them yeah because they
don't have to deal with Kojima they just
all they have to do is just license it
out to him I like that a lot I guess
I'll take em healer let's try it out
let's try the to healer thing this this
is where the meta is born you've got it
we've got to do the groundwork it's a
theory crafting Oh everyone's offended
me
so I'm not a businessman but the whole
like I don't know there was like a lot
of aspects to the whole like kijima it
can you know Kaname thing but one part
of it was like I know he just like would
take forever and spend a lot of money on
those games but like medgar 5 sold like
a ridiculous amount of copies didn't it
I think so it's like I'm curious like
what the like budget versus return whoa
I almost got hit by that train was all
these little trains I like this now this
is a fun map oh this is the one with the
sister cool yeah I haven't seen this one
before
boom oh I think I just did a combo on
this guy yeah so I think the music and
the steam is dynamic how is it maybe
like it keeps changing there's not like
a single track that keeps going I think
okay gotta go to a
I almost killed the bird lady I almost
won a 2v1
all of them gs5 I like them just five
but I'm curious what it would have been
if it had more time
Oh like if it had been finished yeah
yeah I still liked it a lot them yeah
yeah remember that that trailer that
shows a lot of cutscenes that straight
up do not appear in that game mm-hmm we
won we made we made a comeback and we I
feel pretty good about that
Oh the highlight was the healer killing
the other healer okay how come nobody's
dropping off anything that is a good
question nobody on my team is actually
dropping off at the point
yeah they seem to only care about kills
and everyone in my team is just hanging
out in the home base this is cool I love
this I have good I have good teammates
maybe I'll buy a skin for this get
Arthur so I saw a person with a skin
that I didn't recognize
I'm because it's not in the this list
and I'm wondering if there's like
unlockables as you love love maybe
there's like a pre-order thing or
something maybe
oh no you would get that out of active
game pass wouldn't you maybe thanks what
if it's a an Xbox thing I'm not sure I'm
not sure what the maybe any notable
gaming releases soon we've got animal
crossing in Doom what do we got to look
forward to Final Fantasy 7 remake it's
probably gonna be really good yeah
honestly I'm okay taking a couple week
break I got Alex I got you know Animal
Crossing I've been playing oh no oh no
I'm mad from the connection thing again
oh okay wait I might be okay now
the punk skin that might be it
no no it's happening again boots it's an
add-on
we got Anton's already for this well
you're doing that I'm gonna I'm gonna
investigate ah come on
well you can join now okay yep
sweet ah jeez I don't like that all
right uh Chiana toss me an invite yeah
I'm hooking you up sweets I'm worried
it's gonna keep happening now I'm hope
it's huh it's the the fun things all
right I'm in don't do it I was actually
doing pretty well
oh there's no reason to be like I don't
know I thought at this point we've kind
of done with like the weird council
worried stuff like I'm excited that more
people get to experience a really good
game that was on PlayStation which which
game we talked about probably horizon
zero dawn I'm guessing oh sure nav I've
never personally gotten that mentality
because like hey you got to play the
game and now other people get to play
the game and it's a great game everyone
gets to play a great game yeah it's a
win-win
I don't know what genre view it's like
lo-fi hip hop dubstep mm-hmm like what
what is what is this exactly supposed to
be so still wild to me to see my xbox
stuff on other things our share all
right we got we got a high high level
healer just wanna go DPS again
hope that guy knows what to do my
connection is poor and you may be kinked
so is it my internet is my internet
what's going on here
oh yeah it's it's oh boy you may be able
to mess with the bit on the stream and
maybe that would free it up a bit or
check and see if like steam or something
is downloading something but I could
check that yeah give me a sec here right
oh let me you stop that I was about to
say like I could I could share my screen
and discord and then you could scream
that now that wouldn't really work the
way you'd want it to it definitely
wouldn't I do a quick speed test
she's not as smooth though stream seems
to be running smooth maybe it's just the
problem with bleeding edge maybe there
are too many people playing bleeding
edge my internet connection is not as
strong right here as but that's because
I'm streaming so but I still should be
able to play
that's enough that I could at least play
so I don't know let's give it another
shot I guess I won't play with you
though cuz you're already in a match
alright kick
and I like how the being kicked from the
party thing isn't a pleasant color like
it's it's not like red or something like
argent
hmmm healer all by himself that's that
stuff I'm insu
oh yes I don't know where the heck
they're going
okay yeah everyone's here
okay so far I'm alright
objectives control starting saying oh
the double Hill men maybe this is just
my guy actually who you buying the the
guitar guy you also keep saying kiss my
axe which is really kind of winning me
over
not about dying though this is about to
happen healer please heal me
whether people out here say the switch
is bad and I don't understand that
yeah wait what the switch is fantastic
oh right
oh we slaughtered them
all right this games good they're being
all jittery but at least I'm okay just
sitting on the objective god I am
murdering thank you for the hills
all right as soon as I get out of this
match I'll wait for you to get out of
that one sounds good we get back back to
together find all the bad guys I don't
even have any other things my hands
can't paint any of these in up turn
noise in my head it's some sort of
notification on my computer
all right I'm gonna go grab these
objectives
[Music]
ting where the heck are all my teammates
beautiful play John Luke thank you oh no
power she goes when she does that
mm see just dripping down there's a bad
idea I'm just gonna die you need to like
lure them all away yeah like this here
we go
ah man I'm just getting chased around by
everyone ah my shadow strike that was
bad thank you okay
I'm just gonna go grab see see you mate
save bay
that's okay we got B and C we're good
yeah you got you got it on lockdown yeah
we're set my dude oh my god you just
flew away
[Music]
I haven't had to turn on the nrq rain
soundtrack in my time playing it's good
sign yeah yeah
who is a bad scene it's a pretty close
match actually okay you exam I'm gonna
bank this one point I have did you grab
all those heck yeah oh no oh well played
ace backup I'm back on the murders what
happening
[Music]
damn they suddenly got a huge lead from
that well they switch their healer up oh
my god they're at a hundred point lead
where our teammates either bump dead
hey Apple devices but the iPod account I
used to do Apple stuff and then I kind
of just stopped I like my Google phone a
lot okay we need to take the I'm missing
out on a lot of like cool game stuff
because you got Apple arcade now and all
that yeah healer
oh come on oh he's almost dead there we
go I mean trudged on gaming David yeah I
feel bad for stadia it's definitely not
a thing for me yeah oh there we go
heels please
objectives deactivated okay cool
like Stadium is a really cool idea but
just it doesn't do what I needed to do
yeah that's how I show about it
disguise this guy's got his skills combo
so well together I love it
Wow geez okay everyone starting over B
I'm gonna go take a we're something
we've we've now resorted to get him the
last of our five points by just murder
exclusively so that's exciting this is
probably the best match of this game
I've ever had because it's the only
match I've had that's actually been a
really good back and forth nice ooh
heel heel heel
boom Oh
grandma's chasing after me I give
backers of a silvery masters real talk
that's I'm kind of really hoping that
Sony figures out yeah they do the same
thing that Xbox is doing right yeah cuz
I love how you're soft going all in on
that so I can play all these games
behind me and clear out so much space
sucker I already got it hey oh alright
[Music]
one more match him out ours is really
close our sweet sweet guitar zombie
really cleaned up
absence bigger than it needs to be I can
see an argument for that yeah kind of
thought somehow I had similar thoughts
like maybe the maps were designed and
they had maybe like five players per
team or something or this was a bit
bigger but you can still kind of make it
work
man I'd really I'd really really like to
see blood-borne you see or at the very
least blood-borne just like with a ps5
enhanced version that like has like 60
frames a second that kind of thing
that's what I'm talking about that
blood-borne cart life you know I really
kind of hope maybe they like cuz
Microsoft has the whole backwards
compatibility thing going like if they
find a way to get servers up for
original Xbox games I was really
thinking they were gonna do that like a
couple III s ago I thought that was
gonna be like a big thing they were
gonna announce but I would like to see
that as well place a little Crimson's
yeah crimson skies most of what I
immediately think of because like well
halo - sure but like you can already
play them on Master Chief collection
although I know that there are some like
subtle differences that hardcore purists
prefer the original you play uh what is
it revolts those like the first Xbox
Live game do that
I'm your life now
full disclosure never finished
blood-borne no shields had me shook
that's fair if that's that's a got to
rely on its it's tough to switch to the
like having to jump in and just keep
going oh no they're coming back
we're so close a blood-borne two would
be a great announcement all right
everybody we got to do it we can't let
him win all this matches so close
talk about cool Bioware games Jade
Empire and kotor the parry window is
very small weight is realized I can pull
up my that environmental hazard
strategy's real good Yeah right they
might they might come back and win this
they're there and make it a really good
progress you know I should play
blood-borne through again my connection
to Xbox has been dropped Oh God oh yeah
Xbox or mic Xbox Live has been having
issues that is true sure this this
quarantine stuff they one damn shoot
that was a good game though I'm not even
like I'm bummed we lost but damn that
was looked really good also thank you a
good match
big fan that was that was well done I've
actually been spending a lot of more
time on my eight my xbox and I've been
thinking because I like game pass well
not even because of you I guess I've
been playing a lot of PSO and stuff oh
right and now I'm like this is totally
an Xbox thing even though I'm playing it
through Steam because I'm dumb but I
kind of feel better like buying it even
though I have game pass already just
because I kind of want to give them more
money it's fair
a party yeah Jordan that was really
close
oh all right I mean yet we're not gonna
lose any more now this is it I'm calling
it that was a fun match that was that
was the best match I've had in this game
so far
dang I mean that a good way it was just
like you know most matches I feel like
are too one-sided is definitely an issue
I've had with this game and that was one
where it felt like both teams were just
like really on point and trying their
hardest I'm just bummed that wasn't
there
me too do you think you're gonna play
you're probably actually play PSO 2 on
PC though right
yeah yeah definitely playing on PC and
the character for Xbox transfers over
from my understanding yes I'm just be
cross play right yeah I'm already
working on it which is good what are we
now play PSO 2 together yet Jordan why
don't we play PSO together also I've
been kind of playing really late at
night I need to hop back in I only
checked out that first beta I haven't
been in the other beta how long's this
other beta been going on for I think
it's supposed to be two weeks whoa so
going on for this week dude heck yeah
too many games right I'll do healer yeah
some people already going for healers
and tanks and I'm like this is a weird
situation to be in
what did you hear what I heard what you
said butter girl oh no he he was talking
to your character he's like I like the
way that you dance and then she's like
you've got a really good stroke so don't
mind your character was talking about a
buttercup
we've got these people already putting
up turrets and warming up people are
going crazy I love it
can't wait for last Muslim Bayonetta I
am so excited for Bayonetta I know that
we got like a really good action game
DMC 5 last year but oh man I can't wait
oh there got 2 healers that's no good
I'm trying to keep the healers busy so
you guys can get some fights on over
there oh boy
yikes oh no I went right into the edge
of the whirlwind something feels there
you go look okay I have to ask only
because coffin brought it up in the chat
because I've been seeing ads for it
everywhere is anyone actually tried
dragon Raja and what the heck is it
because all the trailers are like
they're playing some 41 music and it's a
person walking through like a fashion
district in like a fake Tokyo area and
then like they get in a sports car and
then they fight a dragon and I just I
need to know but I don't want to
download it yeah
I could probably just look up like a
gameplay video of your song but probably
I feel like I might as well you know
source it from the channel over here
yeah Capcom really really came out a
strong way no no no one's here I should
leave well sure you can
heal yourself by double-tapping I almost
forgot about that when I was playing
earlier now you guys hear that's like a
mobile second life but with combat oh
man people saying that it's actually
pretty good that's interesting I've
literally never heard of this game oh
I've been seeing ads for it everywhere
and I actually like it they show up a
lot on tick tock
which is how I ran into the Sun 41 1 Oh
interesting because it's like they just
do the trailer but with different
license to music a whole bunch
no actually pretty stoked about how well
that uh that Holt went for me it took it
we got to take see though
oh yeah it's this way he was running
towards it
oh trains are coming yeah they're
healers grabbing it from him ever mind
they're you know I'm not gonna grab it
from him cuz the Train oh you can ride
the train what I think's yeah right you
just if you jump on it correctly it
looked like it was too fast I was scared
then I landed on it by accident all
right we got c-suite head this way
before the doors close and get to be I'm
on be
I'm gonna go quickly snag a I made a
mistake going down here whoo no nope
that doesn't work okay Oh
Vanessa six like I do oh I like many
people needed something to fill the void
the vine left when it went away and I
took shelter in tick-tock
I tried bite the bite just seemed like a
bunch of people complaining about people
pushed in tick-tock so I just stopped
use now I've gotta yeah jumping on the
train I'm coming okay that was good that
was that was decent
objectives activated yeah
but the door is is having tick-tock an
adorable thing
hmm just send it right back to you I
love it no he got away
I guess I'll hang out at baby that
sounds good I'm on my way back to you
first time I see a competitive third
person yeah it's not a thing you see a
lot of yeah that's why I'm rooting for
this game cuz I'm like hey you know I
have it all rolls in LA
oh she was waiting for me she knew oh no
no no you and you I'm here with you I'm
healing you I'm healing you Oh God
I appreciate it oh we just we're out man
there
ah people people think I'm adorable oh
oh wait why people are being real nice
all the time but I'll take it
all right somebody's come oh man
I'm excited for that big same
I put them on the train they got sent
away nice oh oh come back come back oh
no oh no I'm getting those connection
issues again game don't you dare
everyone everyone stop breathing God
dang oh ah
so we'll be out of here in a bit I think
maybe no cuz that's 30 seconds for the
next objective oh you're right
damn come on and I'm really curious if
this is my Internet or if it's the game
because this is the first I have not had
this happen yet the whole time we've
been streaming yeah I don't know mmm
what a bummer
well I guess I'll have to solo it again
dang
ah man
we're we winning we are closed right
aren't we isn't the magic are behind you
know we're not too far off okay
no you leave no not yet it's okay I
gotta I gotta find a way to get a heel
out here now oh yeah you lost your
healer yeah I think they're a person
replaced you still hasn't picked the
character so we're actually just playing
with three people sick it's not the
optimum way to be doing this much is
true I know the trains coming again
[Applause]
okay who should I be here I was thinking
with my boy I feel about the game
overall I like it
it's a fun game I'm not sure how long
it'll last
like the playerbase yeah but I like what
it has and I hope that they continue to
support it and add more stuff to it big
scene I think the games got a really
good foundation I could see this like
maybe getting a few new characters and
then coming back as like a game games
with gold or something and then have a
whole bunch of people play it it's a
very game yeah it's good I think it's
just a deuce board it just needs more
stuff
[Music]
someone's a dino crisis waiting on that
that Dino Crisis remake where's the Hat
oh no wonder if I can like camp out and
try to join it like someone leaves your
game but you could
collection face complete yeah I feel
like Dino Crisis is it like some I keep
saying it but someone at Capcom had to
be like you see how well Ari - did let's
do that one with the dinosaurs game and
I they have to
there's someone had to have set it
somewhere somehow know some way and I
don't I don't get it
I'm also catching up on the the chat Oh
14 power sounds oh hell yeah so soon
they're getting no that's another thing
that Jordan brings up bleeding edge is
already getting a gangster like Japanese
speaking dolphin the drives of Matt cuz
a tank character okay
so there's there's stuff happening that
sounds great I know that I just hope it
continues need to but also a yoke is a
dolphin is wonderful also a tank
character too so that's good
love the new timeslot yeah I feel like a
lot of people might might be into the
the 2 p.m. thing I prefer it personally
like a Solingen streams it's it's after
lunch it's after lunch until a bit
better I've kind of had a chance to go
through my day and plan things out and I
think it just works out a lot better
yeah also more people are home like on
the East Coast and suffer more people
are home in general now more people are
home and I hope you're home I hope
you're not watching this from somewhere
else if you are go back home what are
you doing stop but uh yeah it's a good
time slot for sure yeah I also kind of
want like hmm no I don't know if they're
gonna give us like you wouldn't give us
like overwatch style events or something
where they've got like PvE or something
for this yeah I think that a PvE mode
would be an interesting or maybe even
just playing against bots I just really
like like I think this game has great
character design like really interesting
character he was like oh yeah I would
play just a single-player video game
with some of these characters can you do
emotes in the game like dance yeah each
character actually has dance that's my
current you mode I have peg yeah
part of me wants to unlock stuff with my
currency but at the same time I feel
like I might want to wait till there's
something that I'm actually more into
yeah I'm just not really into anything I
could get boards though there's some
pretty cool-looking boards which
Microsoft would support they're fighting
and scalenes thing would have been huge
they supported killers things way more
than I thought they wouldn't to be fair
yeah I expected to get as much toughest
did they got the win he got three
seasons for it to stop and I was
surprised even after like they lost
their original developer I love that
game so much it's really good I agree I
wish they had just kept going with it
but I guess at a certain point there is
some diminishing returns on their end
one point people were like oh this is
gonna be like the smash brothers but for
Microsoft and that was an exciting
prospect cuz there's so many crossover
characters in their trail
oh man came after one of these these
characters being in that game I'd be
into it they fit in real well I should
point I should play killer instincts
killer instinct is that like American
version of of like the anime that just
is every aesthetic at once yeah you know
I don't have something saying it's great
like you can just put whatever you want
also the the first two seasons
soundtracks are done by mick gordon mmm
that's right which is even better
because you got the guy who did the do
music doing music for a fighting game
some very good versions of all the
character themes in there they also
added sony mode so there's literally
like a like a choose your own adventure
style light
where are my teammates oh god just
everything
[Music]
so video where the killer instinct devs
got food on stage what why who what did
that happen who would do this
Nordia what the context was though man
what what if we played killer instinct
one of these these Fridays yeah which
does was it wasn't the original devs
that end up getting bought by Amazon or
is it oh wow what is what's the name
galaxy I can't see anyone booing iron
galaxy I think I don't know I've seen
I've seen some wild things what when so
if if you don't know John Luke at night
this is my time to do a promo because
yeah we stream every weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific but John Luke and I usually do a
show every Friday will then play games
with you guys so it would be on a Friday
slot but we'd have to like work out I
think this Friday we're still thinking
of doing animal crossing one heck yeah
all right let's try doing one more match
and we'll call it I like it
also I didn't realize how much time had
passed
mm-hmm now we're at the ensel so quick
yeah I I still like this game I feel
like how did you feel like it's a it's a
good time I'm unplayable I'm gonna leave
I'm gonna leave it installed and I'ma
keep playing
it's invited me to a party
getting my party I'm in let's wait until
I get booted and then if I get booted
[Music]
fair enough
that'd be fun you guys are fun we try to
be fun like a lot of people tend to
forget that video games are meant to be
a thing you're just to have a fun time
playing it so my favorite thing about
them and I'm glad that we can help
convey the fun attitude and hopefully
give you guys something to enjoy
especially in the times that we're in
but uh yeah I'd really like to play some
killer instincts costs another one that
I was thinking of they'd be really good
samurai shodown is coming out in PC
eventually you get the room back on that
yeah apparently is an epic game store
exclusive and that does kind of break my
heart to hear that those people got
booed in any situation they work real
hard and it's not I feel bad if anyone
gets booed unless they they're bad they
they work it they're good
what if what if bleeding-edge gets the
type of support that siege did what if
bleeding-edge becomes the new seed
that's that's what I'm looking for
hopefully even if we have a rocky start
maybe we can become the next siege yeah
all right so you want to do healing
still okay I guess I'm gonna do tank and
I think by the looks of it
one day perhaps you shall show me what
hi all right oh this is this is back
where we started I think we could
probably do a community Fridays on PSO
at some point sooo once that becomes
more available
oh no clue I feel like because the way
that this beta rolled over it looks like
it's like the full launch version yeah I
feel like this might be like a build up
to a soft launch or something but if
anyone is playing though and hasn't
decided on where they're rolling I know
a lot of people that I know are on ship
too and that's probably what we're gonna
mostly be if we do stuff we're already
on the point we're already doing this
everyone's
we're already focusing the healer yeah
we did it this is it this is the match I
didn't even notice
thank you all right I'll play that fixed
it a little bit Thank You Jordan almost
putting I'm just a sunscreen hot asleep
that's a lot damn there's so much in
that video game I did not do that I
never finished it Alessandra was really
into like just doing everything he might
he might be the closest person I know
oh Jordans in the end of the Assassin's
Creed games to I don't know if he's
oh my god this guy it might be the best
tank I think
visibility's really makes sense
come on mr. dealer you're right there no
I fell off the edge do it I'm gonna I'm
gonna go for C though I think I'm maybe
if you're good to hold back on beam
I'll grab seeing them to come back is
there guys there don't do it don't do it
you are actually alright you got a
couple of them over here now
[Music]
those rascally healers I really liked
fighting in shadow of Mordor like those
those games feel good to play and it's
impressive I'm gone I've got a dps in a
tank on me
I'm gonna die
dang it I almost got him so there isn't
a block button in this game for anyone
pointing out you can parry though but
the window is very very small for it I'm
going for that healer I'm not going for
that healer
is the activated
well that guy's got to be upset about
that said just found our healer yeah so
you got a channel that blood-borne oh oh
I found everyone
why are they all over here like this
I do think you like deaf falling is the
ultimate way to do this because you you
can't mess with a whole group unless
you've got your whole group
[Music]
[Music]
Oh as a bunch of people who just fell
what what what was that
that was weird yeah also how are we
winning I don't know
I just look at the score I'm like just
being dying but somehow I'm winning
hello there we go these microphone tanks
absolute pain especially right now yeah
oh I went to be but no one went with me
[Music]
didn't that replay was actually really
cool though okay now they're winning
dude I hate this freaking hit tank he
all he does is chase me he's very good
[Music]
Yeah right
oh it's it's them mic technology it's
always wild over here okay when we get
back into the office it's gonna be
perfect smooth sailing you know
hopefully ideally
[Music]
the healers dead okay thank God dang it
oh and I'm gonna die yep yep there we go
yeah I feel like having a full dedicated
beanie team is definitely the best way
to make this game work
yeah like only be able to communicate
with half a team is better than no
communication but it's a lock right it's
a real spicy time I'm gonna grab the
nope nevermind for some reason our
healers off by themselves and I'm I'm
just gonna hang out with them I guess
got him
Kevin just hold a we have a chance we
can do this Joe geez
I am doing a 3v1 right now out of the
Gila showed up again I'm seeing it I'm
seeing it oh my god
well you're distracting them while we
get all these points I guess so
so I'll take it
I am running back to you guys though I'm
bringing the party to you
no no why would you do that so don't
want to die
woo I'm really good at dodging this guy
I do that give us a lead hell yeah
it's gonna be the same objectives so
it's gonna be a fight we need to really
go all out on this one that bird lady's
super fragile by the way oh yeah
yeah get out of here
I'm gonna work on the tank a bit just
because the dealer isn't here yet
well the he was coming in though Oh
freaking tank man
yeah he's oh yeah I got me one just like
that whoo
that's good way to end it so the music
is actually really good
no I like the music too there just needs
to be more of it I think guys having fun
playing this yeah yeah I'm genuinely
having a fun time playing with it I
would say if this game interests you and
especially if you have game Pass get in
and play it now there's still people
playing it yeah cuz who knows how long
it's gonna last
yeah exactly I really hope that me too
I hope it finds this audience so yeah
that's that's bleeding edge despite all
the weird tech issues on my end I think
this was a very successful stream I had
a fun time you had a very good time yeah
I hope you guys had a good time as well
so mods I got real quick then you want
to give them the spiel while I'm I'm
checking this out oh yeah
again we stream every weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific you can find us all here a ton
of people jean-luc and I though we do a
show usually on Fridays where we play
games with you guys
this week we're still thinking of Animal
Crossing so if you're having a good time
in that or you have some really cool
like designs or things you want to show
off come on by or just have a chill time
it'll be great fun that you got Persia
and Richie and all usual people always
hanging out it's always a good time
playing all sorts of new things old
things wild things strange things the
only way to find out just subscribe so
you don't miss a single one yeah thanks
for watching guys
yeah now I'm gonna awkwardly shut the
stream off
goodbye everybody
you